Speaker 1: So tonight, Ron DeSantis will announce
his candidacy.
He has the audacity to challenge Donald Trump's
path to the 2024 Republican nomination.
Donald Trump wasting no time and starting
to post even engaging caps Lock to Truth,
Social truth Censure.
Trump posting.
As news broke of Ron Desantis's impending
candidacy.
Quote Look, Rob, the sanctimonious came to
me asking for help.
He was losing badly by 31 points to popular
Agriculture Commissioner Adam Putnam.
He was getting ready to drop out of the race,
ran a terrible campaign.
Ron told me he had one last chance.
My support and endorsement, which Putnam and
everyone else wanted.
Also, I gave it to Ron and the race was over
in one day.
He went from losing badly to winning by a
lot.
It actually took four months, but okay, who
cares about the details?
With three large Trump rallies.
He won the general election in an upset disloyal.
This is how Trump sees everything, not just
politics.
And many Republicans see it this way, although
maybe not to the degree that Trump does.
I did something for you, and now you should
essentially have a loyalty that is almost
an indentured servitude to me.
For the rest of your political career.
You should never, ever, ever run against me
because I helped you.
And and that is the sort of moral foundation
to the extent that it is one for Donald Trump.
Trump continuing on troth and then engaging
Capps Lockyer quote Ron Desanctis can't win
the general election or get the nomination
because he voted to obliterate Social Security,
even wanting to raise the minimum age to 70
or more, voted to badly wound Medicare and
fought hard and voted for a 23% tax on everything
sales tax.
He was and is a disciple of horrible RINO,
Paul Ryan and others, too many to mention.
Also, he desperately needs a personality transplant.
That's true.
And to the best of my knowledge, they are
not medically available yet.
A disloyal person.
Trump then continuing in all capital letters.
I built the greatest economy in the history
of the world no inflation, energy independence
and soon dominance, the strongest border ever.
Record, best employment numbers, biggest tax
and regulation cuts.
Rebuilt our military, no wars with Russia,
Ukraine or China, Taiwan or anywhere.
And the U.S. was respected all over the world.
What else can I say?
Almost everything there is a lie.
And then one more troth.
All caps, short and sweet election interference.
So if Trump is this triggered by the news
that DeSantis will be announcing his candidacy
tonight, just you wait for what Trump is going
to do after tonight's announcement.
This is going to be one of the ugliest Republican
primaries that I've ever covered, certainly,
but maybe for an even longer period than that.
I would expect videos, I would expect attacks,
interviews, furious interviews, hopefully
with significant audio trouble.
That's always the best.
But we will be following all of it.
And I hope you'll join me tonight shortly
before 6 p.m. Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific, we
will be covering the DeSantis announcement
with Elon Musk.
Trump will probably attack Elon Musk tonight
as well.
It's going to be wild.
And again, the political objective for me
is for the ugliness of the forthcoming Republican
primary to be as damaging as possible to whoever
eventually becomes the Republican nominee.
Likely Trump, but maybe not.
Also, Monday, Memorial Day.
This is it, guys.
We're it.
We're going to do it.
Monday, Memorial Day, we are launching a one
day membership special.
As many of you know, membership is the primary
funding source for this program.
We are going to discount membership in order
to entice people.
Hopefully you to sign up on Monday.
All you need to do to take advantage of this
membership special is get on my newsletter.
That's really it.
You don't need to get anything notarized.
You don't need to send any smoke signals or
fax anything anywhere.
You don't need to build a Lego train or anything
like that.
You simply get on my newsletter at David Packman
dot com Monday morning, you'll be notified
and then everyone
will
be winning.